arthur edwards y sont tu plaisantes
c'est moi qui les fais rentrer antenne 2
ah bon comment ça ben et moi envoyé un
projet ça m'a plu j'ai présenté à la
chaîne
ça s'est fait comme ça un accord n'était
pas dans la confection toi j'ai
plusieurs ça fait elle est bien ces
missions sont faits avec des sosies de
ça vous aime bien
elle est bien et c'est même moi qui ai
eu l'idée
bon tu m'avais pas dit ça parce que
j'aime pas me planter
bon alors on va boire un coup après
l'émission chez moi de rares dix au je
préfère pas parce qu'il ya de sharon qui
a peut-être passé comme ces deux là ils
s'apprécient pas trop tiens tiens salut
thierry bon il n'a pas évolué entre nous
avec de l'eau je fais pareil